Depuis maintenant plusieurs mois, vous n’avez
certainement pas échappé à la déferlante
des images qui sont générées par des intelligences
artificielles, des IA. Qu’il s’agisse
de DALL·E, de Midjourney ou encore de Stable
Diffusion, il existe maintenant plusieurs
programmes extrêmement efficaces, capables
de créer de toute pièce une image à partir
d’une description.
Et ce que font ces IA, ça n’est pas du
Google Image. Elles ne vont pas chercher une
image existante, mais elles produisent des
images nouvelles, qui n’existent pas, et
qu’elle créent à la demande. Il peut s’agit
de photographies, de peinture ou d’art numérique,
et on peut même parfois spécifier le type
d’objectif photo ou le style du peintre
que l’on souhaite retrouver.
On appelle ces types d’algorithmes des IA
génératives, car elles sont capables de
créer du contenu à la demande, en intégrant
à la conception une part d’aléatoire,
de façon à pouvoir obtenir plein de variations
à partir de la même demande.
Si vous avez essayé ces IA génératives,
vous avez peut-être été comme moi ébahis
par leurs capacités à faire quelque chose
qui semblait impossible il y a seulement quelques
années. Ca parait presque magique tellement
ça fonctionne bien. Mais au fait, comment
ça fonctionne vraiment ? Eh bien c’est
ce qu’on va voir ensemble aujourd’hui
!
[jingle]
Commençons par quelques remarques de base
sur la terminologie. Ce qu’on appelle l’intelligence
artificielle, c’est un domaine aux contours
un peu flous. On peut dire que son objectif
est de réaliser à l’aide de machines,
des tâches traditionnellement réalisées
par des humains, et dont on estime qu’elle
requièrent de l’intelligence. Sans trop
préciser le sens qu’on donne à ce terme.
[DIAGRAMME Au sein de l’IA, il y a un champ
de recherche assez bien identifié qu’on
appelle le machine learning, ou apprentissage
automatique. L’idée est de s’attaquer
notamment à des questions d’IA, en mettant
au point des algorithmes capables d’apprendre.
Et qui réalisent leur apprentissage à partir
de données auxquelles ils ont accès.
Et dans le machine learning, il y a le deep
learning. Et ça, c’est l’idée d’utiliser
une classe assez spécifique d’algorithmes
que sont les réseaux de neurones profonds,
et qui ont connu un énorme succès depuis
une dizaine d’années.]
Aujourd’hui quand on utilise le terme IA,
il s’agit presque systématiquement de deep
learning, tant cette approche est efficace.
Je ne vais pas évoquer ici les principes
de base du deep learning, j’avais fait toute
une vidéo sur le sujet il y a quelques temps,
je vous invite à aller la voir si ça vous
intéresse.
Quand on parle d’algorithmes capables d’apprendre,
cela fonctionne souvent selon le même principe.
Imaginez qu’on veuille créer un algorithme
qui soit capable de reconnaitre ce qu’il
y a sur une image.
[ALGO On veut un programme à qui on donne
une image en entrée, et qui produise un mot
en sortie. Et on veut que cet algorithme réponde
«Chat» sur cette image, sur celle-ci
«Voiture», etc. Pour réaliser cela,
on va utiliser ce qu’on appelle de l’apprentissage
supervisé.
Au départ notre algorithme va être ignorant,
et répondre n’importe quoi quand on lui
présente une image. Et puis on va lui fournir
une grande base de données d’exemples.
C’est-à-dire des milliers d’images de
chats, de voiture, de tasses, avec à chaque
fois la réponse qu’on attendrait de lui.]
En utilisant ces exemples, l’algorithme
va peu à peu ajuster ses paramètres pour
s’améliorer, il va apprendre. Jusqu’à
être capable de réaliser lui-même le travail
de façon suffisamment correcte. On dit alors
que l’algorithme aura été entrainé, et
on pourra commencer à l’utiliser.
Cette façon de faire, c’est donc l’apprentissage
supervisé. De façon plus générale si on
veut qu’un algorithme prenne en entrée
X et réponde Y, on lui donne une base de
données d’exemples (x,y), et on l’entraine
en espèrant qu’il va finir par savoir faire
le lien.
C’est ce qu’on appelle parfois une tâche
de prédiction, puisqu’on donne X en entrée
et on demande à l’algorithme de prédire
Y. Dans mon premier exemple X ce sont des
images et Y ce sont des mots. On classifie
les images avec des mots. Mais le principe
fonctionne avec plein d’autres concepts.
Par exemple X ce peut-être toutes les caractéristiques
d’une transaction bancaire, et Y est une
classification pour estimer si la transaction
est frauduleuse ou pas. Ou bien X c’est
le texte d’un e-mail et Y c’est une classification
entre Spam/Non-spam. Beaucoup des applications
actuelles concrètes du machine learning reposent
sur ce principe d’apprentissage supervisé,
qui permet de réaliser des tâches de prédiction.
Ca semble un peu magique présenté comme
ça, de penser qu’un algorithme peut reconnaitre
des images et associer les bons mots, mais
il faut bien voir que tout ce que fait l’algorithme,
c’est de manipuler des nombres. Tout se
fait via des opérations mathématiques.
[CHIFFRES Par exemple sur la classification
des images, voici comment on fait en pratique.
On définit d’abord un nombre fini de catégories
: «Chat», «Voiture», «Tasse»,
etc. Et on leur attribue des numéros : 1,2,3
etc. On peut faire disons 1000 catégories,
et à chaque image de notre base de données
on va associer une de ces 1000 catégories.
Et pour l’image elle-même, on va aussi
la représenter comme une série de nombres.
Une image 600x600, ce sont 360 000 pixels,
chacun de ces pixels va être codé en rouge/vert/bleu
donc il faut 3 nombres par pixel. Au total
je peux décrire complètement mon image en
un peu plus d’un million de nombres.
Donc ce que je cherche à faire, c’est un
algorithme qui prenne en entrée une série
d’un million de nombres qui représentent
l’image, et qui me crache en sortie un nombre
entre 1 et 1000 représentant la catégorie
qu’il pense être la bonne.]
On n’a pas besoin d’expliquer à l’algorithme
ce qu’est une image, un chat ou une voiture;
lui, il manipule juste des nombres. Et il
va s’en faire une idée tout seul en essayant
de mettre en relation les valeurs des pixels
des images et les 1000 catégories qu’on
aura prédéfinies.
Ces algorithmes de classification d’images
fonctionnent maintenant extrêmement bien,
avec des performances proches de celles des
humains. Alors intuitivement, on se dit que
ça, ça n’a pas l’air très très éloigné
de ce qu’on voudrait faire pour générer
des images.
[REVERSE Pour classifier des images existantes,
en entrée X on a des images, et en sortie
Y un mot qui les décrit, et une base de données
pour réaliser l’entrainement. On n’a
qu’à entrainer un algorithme du même genre
sur la même base de données, mais à l’envers.
On lui donne un mot en entrée, et on attend
qu’il produise une image en sortie. Facile,
non ?]
Eh bien non, ça ne marche pas comme ça.
Il y a plusieurs raisons à cela. Dans une
tâche de prédiction, comme la classification
des images, on donne en entrée beaucoup d’informations,
des centaines de milliers de pixels, et en
sortie on récupère quelque chose de très
limité, juste un numéro de catégorie par
exemple. L’algorithme de classification
réalise en quelque sorte de la synthèse
d’information.
Ici c’est l’inverse qu’on veut, on donne
très peu de choses en entrée, disons juste
un mot. Et on s’attend en sortie à récupérer
une image entière, qui contient donc beaucoup
plus d’information que ce qu’on a mis
au départ. Ca ne peut pas marcher avec un
simple apprentissage supervisé.
En fait si, on peut essayer. Mais ce qu’il
risque de se passer c’est que notre algorithme,
une fois entrainé, chaque fois qu’on lui
demande une image de chat il va nous ressortir
exactement l’image de chat qu’il avait
dans sa base de données. Ou bien une sorte
de moyenne de toutes les images de chat qu’on
lui a fournies. Et c’est pas ça qu’on
veut.
L’autre aspect important, c’est qu’on
veut que notre algorithme de génération
d’image ait une part d’aléatoire. Si
je lui demande 50 fois un chat, je veux qu’il
me produise 50 images différentes, pas 50
fois le même chat.
Générer ça n’est pas la même chose que
prédire. Donc vous voyez que pour créer
des images à partir d’un texte, prendre
une approche traditionnelle de prédiction
par apprentissage supervisé, eh bien ça
ne va pas marcher. Il faut faire autrement.
Alors voyons comment.
[jingle]
En 2014, une première façon de faire assez
efficace a été proposée par une équipe
de l’Université de Montréal : les réseaux
adversariaux génératifs, ou GAN en anglais.
Alors qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ce truc.
Pour voir ça, prenons un problème plus simple
que celui que j’ai évoqué. Imaginons pour
commencer que je veuille uniquement créer
des images de chat.
[GAN Je dispose d’une grande base de données
d’images de chat, je veux juste être capable
d’en créer plein d’autres, de nouvelles,
qui n’existent pas initialement dans la
base, et qui ressemblent bien à des chats.
Pour cela, je vais entrainer non pas un, mais
deux réseaux de neurones.
Le premier, on va l’appeler le faussaire.
Il aura pour rôle de générer aléatoirement
des images à partir d’une série de paramètres.
Et le deuxième, on va l’appeler l’expert,
et sa tâche va être simple : si on lui présente
une image, il va devoir apprendre à reconnaitre
si l’image est une vraie image de chat,
qui provient de la base, ou bien une image
inventée.
Rappelez-vous le principe de l’apprentissage,
au début ces algorithmes sont mauvais. Le
faussaire, quand on lui demande de produire
une image de chat, il va produire des images
de ce genre, du bruit complet. Et l’expert,
quand on lui présente deux images en lui
demandant quelle est la «vraie», au
début il va répondre au pif.
Et puis à force d’essais et d’erreurs,
ces réseaux vont progresser car à chaque
fois on leur donne le résultat. On indique
au faussaire s’il a réussi à berner l’expert.
Et l’expert lui sait s’il a correctement
discriminé les images qu’on lui présente.
Au départ, l’expert va assez vite apprendre
à reconnaitre les vrais chats des fausses
images, qui sont initialement assez pourries.
Et puis peu à peu le faussaire va progresser
et faire des images qui seront de mieux en
mieux, et ça va forcer l’expert à améliorer
son niveau.]
Et en laissant les deux s’entrainer ensemble
suffisamment longtemps, on finira si tout
va bien par avoir un faussaire capable de
produire des images très semblables aux vraies,
et un expert qui aura bien du mal à faire
la différence. Ce principe d’entrainement,
on l’appelle «adversarial», puisque
les deux réseaux de neurones s’affrontent
et progressent de concert. C’est comme si
vous demandiez à deux joueurs de foot de
s’entrainer ensemble : l’un fait le tireur
de pénalty et l’autre le gardien, avec
l’idée qu’ils vont conjointement progresser.
Ces réseaux adversariaux génératifs, ou
GAN, existent maintenant depuis plusieurs
années, et vous les avez certainement vus
à l’oeuvre si vous connaissez le site This
Person Does Not Exist.
[THIS PERSON Sur ce site, on a des réseaux
ont été entrainé à partir de photos de
visages, et qui sont donc excellent à inventer
de nouveaux visages de toute pièce. Il y
a parfois des défauts mineurs mais dans l’ensemble
c’est assez bluffant.
Dans le même genre, vous avez aussi pour
les voitures This Car Does Not Exist, pour
les maisons This House Does Not Exist, et
ah oui, bien évidemment : This Cat Does Not
Exist.]
Ce type d’algorithme donc est très efficace
pour produire des images d’un type donné
et fixé à l’avance. Si l’entrainez sur
des chats, il vous fera des chats. Mais vous
voyez qu’on n’est pas encore au stade
où on peut rentrer librement du texte et
avoir une image qui mélange plusieurs concepts.
On va y venir, mais avant ça, prenons un
peu de recul et essayons de comprendre la
différence entre ce que font les réseaux
génératifs, et l’apprentissage supervisé
qu’on a vu avant, celui qui permet par exemple
de classifier des images.
[COMPARAISON Dans l’apprentissage supervisé,
on donne X en entrée, et on attend que l’algorithme
nous prédise Y en sortie, et pour ça on
lui donne plein d’exemples de X et de Y.
Avec les réseaux génératifs, on donne plein
de X en entrée, par exemple des images de
chat, et on dit à l’algorithme «Vas-y
donne m’en d’autres».]
[2D Essayons de se représenter la différence
en imaginant qu’il n’y ait que deux dimensions.
Par exemple si X et Y sont chacun de simples
nombres réels. Dans ce cas là on peut représenter
chaque exemple (x,y) de la base de données
comme un point dans un diagramme en 2D.
Dans l’apprentissage supervisé, on veut
que l’algorithme puisse prédire Y à partir
de X. Donc en gros on veut que notre algorithme
arrive à faire une sorte de régression,
qui lui permette de deviner à peu près la
valeur de Y si on lui présente une nouvelle
valeur de X qu’il n’a jamais vu dans la
base.
Ok maintenant comment ça se passe pour un
algorithme génératif, à qui on demande
de construire de nouveaux exemples à partir
d’une liste de X. Imaginez que dans mon
cas X soit en 2 dimensions, donc décrit par
deux nombres. Deux c’est pas beaucoup, tout
à l’heure une image on a dit que c’était
1 million valeurs, mais nous on va en regarder
que deux. Appelons les x1 et x2.
Donc ma base d’exemple c’est une liste
de valeurs (x1,x2). Imaginez que je représente
chaque exemple dans un diagramme et que j’obtienne
ça. Ou bien ça. Manifestement il se passe
quelque chose. Dans mon premier cas on voit
que tous les exemples sont groupés dans un
certain coin. Dans mon second cas, on voit
qu’il y a comme une structure sous-jacente.
Si on me présentait une base de données
de ce genre, je serai capable de dire quelque
chose d’intéressant sur la façon dont
sont répartis les exemples, sur leur distribution.
Ils ne sont pas quelconques, il ne sont qu’une
petite partie de l’espace total des possibilités.
Et avec les images de chat c’est pareil.
Ok il y a 1 million de dimensions donc c’est
dur à visualiser, mais les images de chat
sont ne sont pas des images quelconques. Dans
l’espace immense de toutes les images possibles
et imaginables, les images de chat ne sont
qu’une minuscule région. Et ce qu’on
veut faire, c’est en savoir plus sur cette
région.
Car si on arrive à dire un truc intelligent
sur la manière dont sont distribués les
exemples d’une base de données, on sera
capable de faire de l’échantillonnage.
C’est à dire de produire de nouveaux points
qui ont de bonnes chances d’être du même
genre.
Dans mes exemples simples en deux dimensions,
si je considère par exemple ces points-ci.
Ou ceux-là dans le diagramme d’à côté.
Ce sont des points qui n’étaient pas dans
les bases initiales, mais dont on a bien envie
de parier qu’ils auraient pu y figurer,
qu’ils ont certainement les mêmes caractéristiques
qui nous intéressent.
Et pareil pour mes chats, je voudrais être
capable de créer une image qui soit nouvelle,
et que j’aille la prendre dans la sous-région
qui contient les images de chat.]
Et vous voyez que cette gymnastique est différente
de l’apprentissage supervisé. On ne fait
pas de la prédiction au sens on me donne
X et je prédis Y. Non, ici, on a ce qu’on
appelle de l’apprentissage non-supervisé.
L’apprentissage non-supervisé, c’est
quand on a des données en entrée qui ne
sont pas séparées en X et Y, ce sont juste
des exemples X, et qu’on essaye de comprendre
comment ces X sont distribués dans l’espace
de toutes les possibilités. De façon à
pouvoir, par exemple, en générer de nouveaux
par échantillonnage.
Evidemment à nouveau d’une part ça ne
se passe pas dans un espace à deux dimensions,
et d’autre part les régions qu’on cherche
à identifier n’ont pas des formes simples.
Ca se voit très bien par exemple par le fait
que la moyenne de deux images de chat ne donne
pas une bonne image de chat.
Mais si vous arrivez à correctement caractériser
la région dans laquelle se trouvent toutes
les images de chat de votre base initiale,
vous pouvez avec une certaine confiance échantillonner
de nouvelles images en allant chercher au
même endroit.
Bien, donc générer de nouvelles images,
ça n’est pas une tâche d’apprentissage
supervisé mais c’est une tâche d’apprentissage
non-supervisé. Et on l’a dit, les réseaux
adversariaux GAN marchent bien pour ça, mais
ne fonctionnent que si on donne plein d’exemples
en entrée. Et il faut le faire pour chaque
type de catégorie qu’on veut générer
: des chats, des voitures, des appartements,
etc.
Les applications sont donc limitées, et cela
explique que l’on n’ait pas vu de choses
très spectaculaire depuis This Person Does
Not Exist. Sauf depuis l’été 2022 avec
l’apparition de DALL·E et Stable Diffusion,
qui n’utilisent pas les GAN. Et donc voyons
maintenant cette nouvelle technique qui fait
fureur en ce moment : les algorithmes de diffusion.
[jingle]
Avant de voir comment les algorithmes de diffusion
sont capables de créer des images en prenant
un texte libre comme point de départ, voyons
déjà comment ils fonctionnent sur la même
tâche que celle des GAN : générer plus
d’images d’un type donné. Le principe
de base est assez simple, et ça semble presque
miraculeux que cela fonctionne.
[BRUIT Imaginez une image de chat. Je peux
essayer de dégrader cette image en la bruitant.
C’est facile, je génère une image qui
est du pur bruit, c’est-à-dire que chaque
pixel a une couleur totalement aléatoire.
Et puis je mélange les deux images avec certaines
proportions. Disons 95% de chat et 5% de bruit.
J’obtiens une image de chat légèrement
dégradée. Et ce que je vais faire, c’est
d’abord une étape d’apprentissage supervisé
: je vais entrainer un réseau de neurones
à débruiter les images.
C’est à dire que je crée une base de données
avec en entrée des images bruitées et en
sortie les images d’origine. Et je donne
ça à mon réseau pour lui apprendre à enlever
le bruit. Ici il doit enlever 5% de bruit.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c’est que je
peux faire ça avec différents niveaux de
bruit. Par exemple je peux bruiter une image
à 45% et à 50%, et entrainer mon réseau
à retirer 5% de bruit pour passer de 50 à
45. Et pareil avec 90 et 95%.
Donc si j’ai une base de données d’images
de chat, je peux toutes les bruiter à plein
de niveaux différent niveaux et entrainer
mon algorithme avec. Et à la fin de son entrainement,
mon algorithme sera devenu super fort à débruiter
des images de chat.]
Maintenant une fois que mon algorithme de
débruitage est entrainé, imaginez que je
lui donne une image qui soit 100% de bruit,
j’ai tiré chaque pixel au hasard. Et que
je lui dise : vas-y débruite là progressivement.
Retire 5% de bruit, puis encore 5%, puis encore
5%. Qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer ?
[DEBRUITAGE Eh bien comme mon algorithme aura
été uniquement entrainé à débruiter des
images de chats, il va progressivement m’inventer
une image de chat à partir du bruit initial.
Et cette image ne sera aucune des images de
la base initiale, ce sera une nouvelle image.
Il va en quelque sorte «halluciner»
une image de chat à partir du pur bruit qu’on
lui donne en entrée.
Et en faisant ça, notre algorithme fait de
l’échantillonnage parmi la distribution
de toutes les images de chat possibles et
imaginables. On tire un bruit au hasard, et
il nous fait une image de chat avec. Cet échantillonnage
est donc une forme d’apprentissage non-supervisé
de la distribution des images de chat.]
Cette idée de génération à partir d’un
débruitage progressif, c’est ça qu’on
appelle les méthodes de diffusion. La technique
a été proposée il y a quelques années
déjà, mais elle vient de connaitre une accélération
grâce à de nombreuses améliorations récentes.
A ce stade de ma description, ce type d’approche
ne fait pas mieux que les GAN. Si vous faites
ça avec des images de voiture au lieu d’images
de chat, vous allez entrainer un réseau de
débruitage qui aura la capacité à halluciner
des images de voiture. Donc on peut génèrer
des images d’un certain type à condition
d’en avoir donné suffisamment d’exemples
en entrée, et de refaire l’entrainement.
Mais il est possible d’étendre le concept
pour le rendre plus polyvalent. Vous vous
souvenez du problème de classification d’images
: on a une grande base de données d’images,
et chacune est associée à une classe : chat,
voiture, visage, etc. Ce qu’on peut faire,
c’est traiter tout d’un coup.
[CONDITIONNEMENT Pour ça on va bruiter ces
images et les donner à notre algorithme pour
qu’il apprenne à les débruiter, mais en
lui spécifiant à chaque fois la catégorie
à laquelle appartient chaque image.
L’algorithme de débruitage sera ainsi capable
de s’ajuster en fonction de la catégorie.
C’est un principe qu’on appelle le conditionnement.
On va conditionner notre débruitage par la
catégorie de l’image.
Et si on fait ça avec une base de données
suffisamment grande, une fois l’entrainement
terminé on aura un algorithme capable d’halluciner
une image en étant conditionné par une classe.
Si on lui dit voiture il va halluciner une
voiture, et chat il va halluciner un chat.]
Alors c’est bien, mais ça n’est pas encore
tout à fait ce qu’on veut. Ici on est limités
par les catégories qui ont été choisies
au départ pour classifier les images. Or
vous voyez que dans DALLE ou Stable Diffusion,
on peut entrer librement du texte, faire des
phrases, des descriptions. Comment on procède
?
Eh bien il va falloir faire appel à certains
algorithmes de traitement du langage naturel,
comme ceux que j’évoquais dans ma vidéo
sur le sujet. Et notamment les algorithmes
permettant de faire ce qu’on appelle de
du plongement, embedding en anglais.
[EMBEDDING L’idée du plongement, c’est
de partir d’un mot ou d’un phrase, et
de lui associer une série de nombres qui
en quelque sorte représente numériquement
son sens, sa signification. Mais plongée
dans un espace mathématique abstrait. De
façon à ce que deux phrases proches aient
des plongements qui soient proches.]
Il existe des réseaux de neurones qui peuvent
réaliser ces plongements, et si on les utilise
avec un algorithme de diffusion, on peut alors
utiliser le plongement pour conditionner le
débruitage.
[CONDITIONNEMENT Ca marche comme tout à l’heure,
mais au lieu d’être conditionné par une
catégorie d’image, notre processus de débruitage
sera conditionné par le plongement de la
description de l’image.
En pratique, on prend des toujours des images
mais cette fois accompagnées d’une description
libre, par exemple une légende. On calcule
le plongement de la légende, et on entraine
notre réseau à débruiter ces images, tout
en étant conditionné par le plongement de
la légende.
Et si on fait ça avec suffisamment d’images
légendées, eh bien on obtient un algorithme
de génération d’image à partir d’une
description.
Vous tapez un texte, l’algorithme calcule
son plongement. Il génère ensuite une image
100% bruitée et ensuite va la débruiter
progressivement, tout en étant conditionné
par le plongement de la description qu’on
a donné.
Et si tout va bien l’algorithme va halluciner
une image en prenant comme contexte la description
qu’on a donné.]
Voici dans les grandes lignes comment fonctionnent
les algorithmes de diffusion comme Stable
Diffusion ou encore DALLE. Bon il y a encore
pas mal de subtilités mais je pense que la
vidéo est déjà bien assez lourde, et je
vous renvoie au billet de blog qui accompagne
la vidéo si vous voulez plus de détails
techniques.
Avant de conclure, il y a un point que je
dois quand même évoquer, ce sont les problèmes
éthiques et juridiques posés par ces algorithmes.
Il y a bien sûr la possibilité qu’ils
offrent de créer de fausses images ayant
l’air complètement plausibles, donc potentiellement
de faire de la désinformation avec.
Il y aussi les question de propriété intellectuelle,
puisque ces algorithmes ont été entrainés
à partir d’images trouvées sur Internet,
et qui ne sont pas forcément libres de droits.
C’est particulièrement criant pour les
dessins ou l’art numérique en général,
puisqu’on peut demander à l’algorithme
d’imiter le style d’un artiste sans que
ce dernier ait eu son mot à dire.
Ces questions sont plus complexes qu’il
n’y parait, et je n’ai pas vraiment les
compétences artistiques ou juridiques pour
les traiter correctement. D’autant que les
choses évoluent très vite et qu’il y aura
certainement des effets de jurisprudence.
Donc gardez à l’esprit ces interrogations
car on risque d’entendre parler pas mal
prochainement.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, merci
d’avoir suivi cette vidéo. N’hésitez
pas à aller voir mes vidéos connexes sur
le deep learning ou le traitement du langage.
Abonnez-vous si ça n’est pas déjà le
cas et n’hésitez pas à venir vérifier
régulièrement les nouvelles vidéos, même
si Youtube ne vous les propose plus.
Pour celles et ceux que ça intéresse, j’ai
aussi créé récemment un serveur Discord
communautaire, n’hésitez pas à le rejoindre
pour venir discuter. Le lien est en description.
Et moi je vous dit à très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos. A bientôt.